وضع جديد للاجئين والمهاجرين يلوح في
الافق داخل القاره العجوز العجوز فالمصير
المشترك لدول القاره دفعها لتوحيد جهودها
بحثا عن ابرام اتفاقيه جديده تخصه ملف
الهجره دول السبعه والعشرون الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترغب في تقاسم مسؤوليه
رعايه اللاجئين والمهاجرين داخل القاره
الاتفاق الاوروبي الجديد حول ملف الهجره
يحمل في طياته بنودا اكثر صرامه حول توزيع
المسؤوليات بين الدول ومن اهم بلوزه
التزامه الدول غير الراغبه في استقبال
المهاجرين غير الشرعيين واللاجئين على
مساعده الدول المضيفه ماديا ولوجستيان هذا
بالاضافه الى تسريع وتيره استبعاد
المهاجرين واللاجئين غير المسموح لهم
بالبقاء
اسباب عديده حركت المياه الراكده ودفعت في
اتجاه مطالبه العديد من الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي باعاده النظر في طريقه
مواجهه توافد المهاجرين واللاجئين الى
اوروبا وبلغت الهجره غير الشرعيه الى
اوروبا او جهه سنه 2016 قبل ان تعاود
الارتفاع خلال السنه الماضيه التي وصل
خلالها 330 الف مهاجر غير نظامي الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر جميع الطرق وتتصدر
دول جنوب اوروبا مثل ايطاليا واليونان
الاعضاء الراغبين في وضع خطه جديده لملف
الهجره على اعتبار انها تستقبل العدد
الاكبر من المهاجرين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات